so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a tree a race of noble boys
heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
I keep having these
memories something in my past is the key
to all of this
you know how to fly this thing you see
that's a yes-or-no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
what you really are
[Music]
I think I had a life here
what are you telling me
you've come a long way
but you know as strong as you think
[Music]
the slaw is just the beginning
I'm not going to fight your war
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got brand
new Captain Marvel footage to break down
and a whole bunch more of the story so
we have a little bit more on her
backstory and how they've changed it a
little bit from the comics this is like
Marvel's week for new footage so we'll
do new round of that IMAX ticket
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment on the video the big
thing here is that they just take you
through the scrolls and explain a little
bit more you get to see talos full-on
you get some voiceover from Ben
Mendelsohn they're talking about the
kree-skrull war I'm not gonna fight your
war I'm going to end it when he says
this war is only the beginning I don't
think that he's talking about infinity
war or Avengers 4 or anything like that
I think that he's just implying that the
scrolls are going to continue spreading
and trying to conquer the universe I do
love the way they recut her clocking
that old lady on the Los Angeles subway
so you see all those people just staring
at her like why is she dressed like that
then just as he mentions her being one
of the good guys
she just clocks her right in the face
like I'm a good guy clocking a little
old lady in the face but as you see
they're super strong - I know people
have been asking about super Skrulls as
far as I know they're nowhere in the
film the way you see Jude Law later they
they sort of call him out a little bit
more as a villain in this trailer he's
still Kree we'll talk about him in a
second because there's just so many
other big ideas that they throw at you
in this when she says that she's part of
a race of noble warrior heroes you can
see that she's kind of drunk the
kool-aid this point in the movie may not
be where she started to try and figure
out what her backstory is yet because
then you get a later voice over where
she's like I'm getting these visions of
a past that I may have had so that might
happen a little bit later with Talos
trying to manipulate her because it
sounds like she's stuck in the middle
like you get to Annette Bening voiceover
we thought that she was playing her
mother in the movie but now you can see
that she's a pink skin cream made to
look a little bit like a human she kind
of explains what's going on when she's
getting her powers here obviously you
don't get the whole scene so there's
still a lot of misleading footage here
but you see her bleeding green Kree
blood I don't think we've seen them draw
this greenish bluish looking Kree blood
since that first guardians of the galaxy
movie but if you missed my earlier
trailer videos yes this is
definitely Korath from the first
guardians of the galaxy film he and
Ronan came back for this they're not
quite as evil during this period in time
but this is meant to be about 20 years
before those events so Ronan is still no
bulk rewar of the Empire he hasn't quite
gone off the deep end yet but I think
that probably has something to do with
this ongoing kree-skrull war
so maybe Captain Marvel has something to
do with precipitating his fall off the
deep end
pretty clear though that she gets into
the accident here she starts bleeding
green Kree blood she's crackling with
energy this is probably after the
explosion that they have later in the
trailer you see someone walking up in a
Star Force uniform that's probably Jude
Law's character then you get more
Annette Bening voiceover finishing the
dialogue saying we found you with no
memory we made you what you are today so
that explains the memory loss but then
you also see her upside down when she
talks about them making her even though
Annette Bening seems like a really nice
person that you would put in a movie
she's played some really hardcore female
characters in her time so it seems kind
of sinister having her do this maybe
she's trying to port Carol Danvers a
whole bunch of kool-aid as they're
filling her with green Kree blood
there's also a really important line of
dialogue that Annette Bening gives us
too that explains Captain Marvel and
present-day
so that you could live longer stronger
so her lifespan has naturally been
extended which explains why 20 years in
the future she would still look like
this young version of brie Larson all
the shots of her with the mohawk giving
off those blasts look like when she's
still part of Star Force they're on a
mission early in the film before she
comes back to Planet Earth so this is
just her being a badass noble warrior of
the Kree Empire without knowing anything
different but the really twisted thing
is that you get a wider shot of her
inside that Mindwipe device and you see
that is one of the scrolls next to her
do you know what you are I know there
are a lot of people that want to back
the theory that she secretly might be a
scroll I don't think that's exactly
what's going on here I do think that
they're trying to maybe implant some
false memories are just mess with her
head but the colour of her blood is a
little bit closer to Creed then it is
two Scrolls Scrolls have more
traditionally green you know solid green
looking blood and hers is more of a
bluish tinge
doodle-oo seems like he was there in the
explosion and the opportunity presented
itself for them to use this
amazing new super powerful weapon that
she says later in the trailer is capable
of ending their war so you just have a
bunch of different people trying to take
advantage of her both the scrolls and
Jude Law's star force character this is
her waking up on that ship you also see
her with Jude Law a little bit later
even though he looks human he's a pink
skin Kree and it's implied that there's
maybe a romance between them I don't
know how much they're gonna get into
that during the film another big shot of
Monica Rambo's mother her giving her
that little call sign someone might show
that to her and she might remember it
from her Air Force days because it's not
clear how much time passes between her
accident getting her mind wiped
and then her winding up back on earth
the ship that they're in here for this
funny scene where he's like do you know
how to fly this seems like a prototype
of one of the quinjets so maybe they'll
pay this joke off during Avengers 4 when
she tries to fly one of them this
obviously doesn't look like planet Earth
so it might be some later big conflict
between the Kree and the Skrulls the
ship where she walks on and you see her
helmet come off she got a little blood
on her lip this seems like the same
scroll ship where you see the scrolls
walking through the corridor here and
you get that ben mendelsohn voiceover
would you like to know what you really
are he's probably the one that spills
the beans that she's really a human that
the Kree manipulated into thinking that
she was a Kree the interesting thing
here too is is it looks like she's
getting into a fight with Talos or one
of the other scrolls in this big
accident here but I do think right after
she gets her powers this scroll is
trying to kill her in this moment before
she figures out what's going on maybe
what happens is is she just
automatically without realizing it uses
her powers and then Jude Law witnesses
that and says okay why don't I just take
the opportunity here to grab this person
that doesn't know who they are and use
them as a weapon against the scrolls in
our war with them seems like Nick Fury
takes her to a shield base where she
starts reading all of her own personnel
files trying to learn more about her
history this shot seems like it's before
her accident happens when they're
chasing each other then they get into
the fight crash then the explosion
happens there's a broken tax she's
looking at that says Carol Dan with the
rest cut off the interesting thing is is
that her Kree name in the movie is just
vers so that's Carol Danvers with the
Carol Dan cut off so the reason they
give her that Kree name is probably
because she has the other half of this
dog tag on her it probably just got
blown up in the explosion that gave her
powers this shot where he says you're
not as strong as you think you are being
really patronizing to her which
obviously it's a big mr. egg because she
is one of the most powerful people in
the MCU is probably happening earlier in
the film before they go on just a
regular Star Force mission this kind of
looks like a Kree ship it's hard to tell
underneath those masks there but they
don't look exactly like scrolls but this
looks like she's just trying to take out
both of these forces obviously the
scrolls are evil they're villains in the
film but also the big twist is is that
Jude Law and the Kree have been
manipulating her like when Talos says
this war is just the beginning
he's probably referring to an escalation
where their war will consume the entire
universe so to make a Thanos pun she
probably wants to stop one side from
using nukes and blowing up the other
half of the universe
which obviously we know later happened
when Thanos assembled the Infinity
Gauntlet
this is Talos in his human form remember
he's one of Coulson in Nick Fury
supervisors all you can say about this
shot though is when she says I'm gonna
end your war is that she has gone
full-blown super saiyan and then
obviously they do the cat so in the
comics her cat is named Chewie after
Chewbacca for Star Wars reference but in
this movie it seems like they're naming
him goose after Top Gun because she's an
Air Force pilot let me know what you
guys think of the trailer in the
comments I definitely think it's better
than the last trailer we got there is a
rumor yes that we're gonna get Avengers
4 footage later this week but I've seen
a bunch of conflicting rumors so be
prepared for it to not drop there's also
a new rumors that they're gonna drop a
spider-man far from home trailer this
week but we might not get that till next
week
so between now and next week we'll have
new Avengers 4 in spider-man far from
home
congratulations TT Wiz you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here for my new Avengers 4
video and click here to learn why Marvel
and Netflix cancelled daredevil thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]